hello everybody this is grandmaster
varacobian and welcome to the
uh tuesday evening class insane in the
end game okay
i'll be the grand master in resident for
the next 10 days
uh for the saint louis chess club so
you're gonna see me doing lectures on
tuesdays and thursdays and sundays as
well okay
so you will see me streaming as well on
the sanford chess lab channel
so you also see me streaming on my own
channel as well so you're gonna see me a
lot on twitch
and youtube the next 10 days or so
but this class is on end game so we're
gonna start
with the uh current position this is a
game
my game akobian versus robzon this is
not the current robson this is the young
ray robson okay
about 12 years
11 years ago i played against him so he
was only rated 24 65
so we reached this position in the us
championship and
i'm going to show you how to squeeze how
to squeeze a small end game advantage
and try to get a victory okay how to get
a victory
i will also uh i'll be also looking at
the youtube uh youtube chat as well
so if you have some questions you can
definitely address
your questions there okay uh so
currently now it's my turn what to do
here why
to play what to do in this position now
we just traded twins guys we just trade
queens on c7
so that's just what happened here
so take take this is what happened
and now what are we going to do
if you have a choice here now he wants
to take your bishop
so what to do in this position
yeah we can retreat the bishop but
that's not going to be fun
so that's that's yeah if you do that
that's not going to be fun
so what can you do here
i decided that i should try to weaken
the pawn structure okay
i decided that i should try to weaken
the pawn structure here okay
[Music]
now i took on f6 now he takes back
and now we go bishop d5
centralizing centralizing the bishop and
now putting pressure
and now we are threatening also rookie
seven okay
we're also threatening rook e7 in this
position
so now my opponent played bishop f5 g4
trying to
abandon the position try to play rook
you know
try to take on f3 and get some kind of
position so i don't know i feel like
there may be
maybe another move he could have done
maybe something a little bit more
like this but then the problem is i have
this move
if you place that i go there
yeah so that's that's that's what i'm
trying to do here
um now i have bishop f7 threat as well
so it's very difficult
bishop f7 threatening to take on d6 so
as you can see in a black is also behind
in development the pieces are now moving
so bishop f7 is very tough
so
opponent played here bishop g4 now i
want to see what you're going to
to do here what would be your
recommendation
no i mean very natural move you have to
you have to play natural right you have
to try to activate your pieces guys i'm
looking at the chat as well now so
if you have any questions you can you
can mention your questions there as well
okay
now let's see here if you can find the
correct continuation here let's see
what are the suggestions here guys for
why to play
what's good
now we have to try we have to try to
activate right we have to try to
activate our
rook okay so now we play here
rook e7
now the attack is to attack the bishop
on f7 and also we have pressure
we also have pressure
so now robson took on f3
of course i don't want my pawn structure
to be compromised okay
i don't want the structure to be
compromised so that's why i'm just gonna
simply take back okay
so i take back
and now what are we going to do here
guys
now he goes bishop if i says you know he
thought okay i will centralize my bishop
i should be able to hold this position
this is what he was thinking okay
but it's not so simple
now no rugby one is a little bit passive
guys no i think we gotta get we gotta
get the rooks into the game rook t1 okay
bring the rook into the game trying to
go to d7
now he goes here rook d8
and you know if if you trade pieces
that's going to help the players
that he's trying to defend okay so
that's going to be helping the player
with the black piece so you don't want
to try to trade pieces that much okay
that's really going to help your
opponent
it's going to help out to him so that's
why you want to
keep the pieces on the board okay so
for that particular reason we played
bishop d5 correct and now we are
attracting also bishop f7 check
bishop f7 check rook takes we have look
to
um
d8 and if he takes here we could take
this guy
take that guy for example and try to
press this position
okay now he goes here
i took
group d6
he just wants to play rook uh he wants
to play rook to d8
and if i play something like this he's
trying to trade
trade and play this move
okay
seven here now i take now he goes here
attacking
we should be two so we reach this end
game okay which is very very hard to win
guys so we have to figure out the plan
here so i need you to think a little bit
and figure out the plan what will be the
correct plan here to try to win this
position
what would be the plan here for block
like a long term you need a long term
plan here
to win this position
hmm
well yeah i don't know you know at the
moment we have um
we have more important thing than the
dark squares we have a problem with the
pin okay
the moment we have a problem with the
pin here guys we can't really
get rid of this pin here this pin is
super annoying
so here i would like to see you um
have a plan plum okay um
well first things first we gotta get our
king into the game right
that king could be helpful so we start
out with king f1
now he goes to b5 now he's attacking on
h2
and you don't want to put your pawns on
the light squares here you want to try
to control some dark squares here as
well
okay you don't want to just play h3 here
some people might do that but now you
you don't want to do that okay
so you want to control some dark squares
here correct see that didn't
now i got skin g7 now what is the next
step here
it's not like a clear clear-cut plan
here you know you have to do you have to
just figure out
the ideas
no we can't go to k7 we can go to k7
okay 7 you're dropping your bishop on d5
so you cannot play okay 7 you're too
tied up you're too tied up to that okay
well first first things first we got to
get our
rook into b5 okay then we we might try
to consider pushing the a pawn so he
plays f5 now he is threatening to play
f4 it's a clever play by my opponent he
wants to get rid of his weakness
okay he just wants to play a four and
get rid of the weakness
now we play f4 very important move
because we want to fix
the bishop okay yeah we play this
ourselves
attacking the bishop now we established
another weakness now on f5 which is
going to be very important in the long
run
and here i have a clever idea that i'm
gonna try to employ here to get rid of
this pin because this pin is very
annoying okay
this pin is very very annoying
now we play king e2 correct because we
want to play bishop b3
he checks king f3
now he's coming back he's just trying to
do the same idea
to pin me so i cannot untangle you know
but now i go rook d3 so i'm going to try
to go king 2 king d2 and then go bishop
c4 see i couldn't just trade it on d1
but i can lift it up
and then now i can slowly prepare kinky
2.
and now i have bishop c4 i was
considering to play h4 as well but
maybe my g3 bomb will be too weak so i
don't want that
so he has a little bit of success now
trading those pounds
but now looks like this f5 pawn is gonna
fall as well okay
looks like the f5 pawn is gonna fall so
now he goes here
king f3
okay five i didn't want him to put the
rook on a2 i wanted to put a look here
so i can take on f5
and then you know play a4 whenever i
want to
i didn't want to just to put a look
behind it on a2
uh because if i play here
he goes here now i mean
it's hard yes i i lose a pawn actually
so it's could be a serious problem
group a3 i got some temples
and i take check
i cannot lose my pawn so again it's it's
it's a technical position
but the fact that he traded rooks it it
actually
made my task really easier guys because
i wasn't expecting i thought he's going
to keep the bishop and try to
create some control but when he played
rook before
i had to of course calculate okay
because once you trade the rooks
a lot of these positions could be drawn
here but can you calculate it
and tell me why this position is not
drawn actually
why this is actually not drawn
yeah but not always sit not always sit
you know sometimes you're drawn
sometimes it's uh
you know two extra pounds is winning so
it's not always
the id the idea okay
um
how i trade now my kink
activity is very important so i start
pushing the a pawn of course you have to
try to push your postpone
now it goes here
what is the plan here because again we
have to be very precise here
what is the correct plan here to win
this
yeah it's very important that a8 is a
light color and i have the
i have a good bishop here if i had a bad
bishop then would have been draw
now i go back here because i want to
create my second plus pawn
with g5 so now he goes here
g5
now i go f5
and now i'm getting ready to get create
my second now time to
i it was tricky because uh if i had gone
here
he may has this trick so probably still
winning but
i played here that way i can open up the
door for my king to get in here okay
i'm getting the king on b5 okay
king c4 king b5 a5 a6
okay king c4 can be five and then i play
five and
a six okay it takes
so yeah actually my opponent simply
resigned because it's just it's totally
hopeless
okay all right
yeah so pretty smooth victory here it it
it shows that you know
not always opposite collar position is
going to be a draw okay so now all this
sometimes you know when you have this
nice two-pawn advantage you can convert
it okay
yeah thank you sid thank you sid
appreciate it yeah carpool style yep
so let's go back again uh the reason i
chose this because it's also
opposite color and often times when we
see this opposite color positions we try
to be afraid of
immediately thinking oh we're not going
to be able to to win this okay
but it's you know you just you just got
to keep trying okay
and that's what i try to do here in this
game i keep trying to pose
problems to my opponent and again
decision not to trade rooks i think this
is very important a lot of people will
just try to snap on d8 right away here
you know
so i would just go here here
you know a lot of people would just go
for this you know yeah but after this
it's it's not much going on here
okay it's you know he's got chances he's
got bishop d4 ideas okay
i don't want his rook to be active
that's that was my idea that's why i put
the bishop here
yeah and then just basically trade
trading and again i idea to find this
rook d3 idea
okay i thought this was a very important
moment as well guys when i played rook
t3
i mean i left the rook up and found this
idea so it's very very very important
okay
otherwise it's not so clear so i lift
the rook up
and have a nice
position now and then i i'm as soon as
this i play i play this
now i'm going back to kinky to plan all
right
very good guys now i have some important
in-game positions we will work on with
you some
some nice end game studies okay
all right hope you're ready we're gonna
try to solve this positions together
okay
uh some of them are gonna be new for me
as well so we we go
we're going to try to work work it out
together okay
let's first start out with this one i
don't know you guys probably seen this
one before
but i you know for a new
you know some of you still going to be
new
and you might not know this so let's do
this one very quickly
all right
all right guys white to play and win
okay why to play and win and
what is the plan here yeah studies are
fun and they help you to improve
your end games your calculation
absolutely
all right so what are we going to do
here
hello hey john abraham how you doing
good to see you
so what's the first move here that we
gotta try to do hello guys hello
aryan hello
we have to make a knight oh that'll be
interesting
that's clever but we can we're pinned
we're pinned sid we can't do that
because if we do that then
you know we would just win the game but
we can't unfortunately
yeah so the first one is very important
you have to try
if you keep trying to check you're not
going to make much progress you're going
to go around the circles okay
so you know you're not going to make
that much progress by just checking you
have to try to
put him in a position where he has to
move his queen okay
so you have to make a move so he can has
to move his queen
uh check check i'm not sure check he
goes up so the correct move is queen b4
yes that puts his king in the sukks
along okay
that puts his king in a six one guys now
he has to do
queen d5 queen f3 queen g2 queen h1 okay
so let's say he goes here if he goes
here now this is a mistake
uh it's not a mistake but it's just
gonna lose so how are you gonna do that
okay so that's the idea
so if he goes here
if he goes here what are you gonna do
ah yeah we could have done a rook
if we want to get if we want to get
fancy yeah we could do that
i don't know if we should but
now again yeah we'll just go check
let's see perfect
what if he goes here
yeah i mean fancy moves are nice but you
cannot play fancy all the time yeah
we go check right
perfect again perfect correct dylan
now when we play here what if he goes
here guys
now again you're going to try to do the
same thing
and if he goes here you're going to
succeed in doing that
right you're just gonna drop it down and
succeed but the problem is now he might
not comply he will go here
and now it's the the whole board you got
to look at the entire board to find the
solution here
all right now i see the answers are
coming now i see that you're visualizing
the entire board guys
and you are finding the astonishing
queen h2 check
deflecting the queen now you check so
the king moves away you take the queen
so he has to take
but now you promote into a queen and
then you
you securing him okay and he cannot do
anything
king has to move thank you for the queen
got it
king moves away take the queen
alright guys excellent so again when you
get into queen end games don't always
think that you have to check all the
time okay
not always not always you have to go
check check check
okay depending on the position
all right yeah you first you put him
into a success okay
and then you will try to win it after
that
all right this is gonna be a really hard
one okay
this is going to be a really hard
position guys i hope you guys ready
there's lots of lots of pawns lots of
calculations here
white to play and win
okay i mean you're talking about six
pawns okay
you're talking about six pawns versus a
bishop
and we're saying white is gonna win it
so what are we gonna do here guys so
first things first
okay what can we do here
i think your first move is clear what
you gotta do because
if you're on play co if you don't play
correctly
if you don't play correctly it's gonna
be a trouble so you don't wanna
you might even lose the game
yeah you gotta lose a tempe king c1 is
the only move
okay because the problem with this move
is actually check
check check and then you lose
okay so that's why
you you're gonna have to go here you
have no choice okay
if you want to win this game and after
d3 now you're going to win
because now you go here bishop d2
and just mate or f5 bishop d2 bishop
so d3 loses d3 loses e4 loses
so he can play f5 or a4 basically he's
got two options okay
f5
now we play with f2 f4
again this bishop has no no other
options you know so he has to try to go
here so which page
now i press f3
and now it's very important actually to
play this correctly right now
it's extremely important you play this
correctly because
you might not even have a draw here so
you have to create a thread you have to
create thread
and you have to force block to start
pushing this f pawn okay
you have to figure out a way to force
him to push the pawn
bishop g3
pressure
now we're trying to take and take on d4
okay now
either here if he plays here you have
bishop e5 and it's made
so he has no choice but to play
f6
yeah and then we have this mate so
that's why he has to play f6
now after f6 we will play bishop to h4
putting pressure on f6
now you you know what is he gonna do
again it's tricky if he pushes the e
pawn you can take and take and mate
d3 you have bishop e1
yeah now we play bishop h4
now he plays a4
[Music]
okay now you have to continue go back
again putting pressure on the pawn
a3 again we're just waiting we're just
waiting with the bishop
now i place here
and as soon as he plays here now
now again this diagonal is getting
weakened diagonal is getting weakened
we gotta put pressure right
there's page four correct now it's let
me take this guy so he has to play f2
now you take now you go here now again
you're threatening to take
he has to go here now you go back here
now turning to take on d4
yeah now it's mate
all right so a lot of back and forth but
it just shows you know that the bishop
is such a strong
piece that position like this you're
playing for a win
six pawns versus bishop but you are
pushing
for a victory guys it just it shows the
strength
of a bishop and of course the the
placement of the poor king on the corner
that that actually plays a whole huge
role for you okay
so and the pawns are doubled yeah that's
important as well
all right very good guys very good
so again back and forth back and forth
with the bishop movement
you can watch this again later uh you
know on youtube
uh you know as soon as it's uploaded you
can just go over the ideas a little bit
more slowly
so you can understand everything okay
all right so now
okay let's see here
i wanted to do this position with you i
think you don't you
some of these positions you've already
did it so let's see here
all right guys let's go here
clear board
all right
i mean this looks like a really tough
position because
it's white to move
white to move and draw okay
the problem is the g3 pawn is very
strong and f pawn is coming in as well
too
so what are we what are we going to do
how are we going to try
how are we going to try to save this
position okay
it's it's it's very tricky because he
just wants to continue pushing
okay
but with the precise calculation with a
precise calculation
you're going to be able to solve that
issue okay
first move is very very important guys
first move is very very important
yeah you basically have to calculate
five moves okay
once you calculate this five moves then
yeah you're going to be you're going to
be in good shape
all right he wants to go g2 and then
play f4 and just just win the game
that's all that he's trying to do
rook b3 correct seed now you can play
here because you have
check and check winning the pawn so the
draw immediately again we're trying to
draw this guys we're not trying to win
this so he plays f4
he has to play f4
now a very important move here needed
you have to you have to figure out uh
that
if you if you let him time to
consolidate 95 kg7 95 f3 he's just gonna
win the game
so you don't have time to let him to
consolidate
so what's the move here rook
f3 now i just want to take sorry rook f3
now you just want to take the pawn
now he can play g2
you have to take what else to do he's
going to coin now
and now what do you do
and it's still made perfect d87 taken d7
taking
f8 f7 cannot go anywhere okay
now what if he tries what if he tries to
be a little clever and says you know
what
i'm not gonna let you do that okay i'm
not gonna let you do that
he's gonna play knight here and control
the g4 square
that way now he can queen and you don't
have anything
what are you going to do against this
idea
well if you do enough practices you'll
be able to see this kind of stuff
yeah you have to do enough practices
okay if you practice enough you're gonna
start
you know you your brain is gonna start
looking for extraordinary things
and now
very special move here needed again
don't don't be scared you can allow him
to quinn because you have another
drawing mechanism okay
you have another drawing mechanism
[Music]
now
look at that look at that still made
here unbelievable
now the knight is covering this square
and the queen is covering this course
and the king is covering this purse
okay you're forcing the checkmate it's
unbelievable
how you can do this on an empty board
empty board it's absolutely unbelievable
okay
that's why you guys got to remember
these things okay and use this in your
games
you know whenever that's why don't give
up when you think that you're dead lost
try to look for that last trick
you got to think about this last trick
you can think about it you can always
resign
yeah think if you can find one more idea
95 i mean this is really this is i can
see it it's fine
it's the knight is covering the squares
but this is kind of
you know another another beautiful idea
95
check here g4 it takes
and forcing and forcing the
steel mate okay guys so again we worked
on some important end games today ray
robson end game and also this
studies this end game studies or
something is very very important
on thursday guys i will have two
lectures okay
so make sure you check out schedule for
those two lectures
on thursday on the saint louis chess
club youtube channel
and also follow me as well on the twitch
uh
i'll be streaming for the chess chess
essentials chess club
and i'll be also doing my own streaming
tonight
and every evening later on okay so my
streams are now going to be later on in
the evening guys around 9 9 30 p.m
central time and during the day i'll be
working for the century chess club and
streaming and doing
a lot of different content for them okay
all right i hope you guys enjoyed this
endgame class and the game against
robson
uh we had a good turnout we see i saw
some familiar
names and thank you everybody for
joining this class
i will see you on thursday for the next
two classes okay this week
all right thanks everybody take care bye
you